we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woke and the corporations we will
never ever surrender Florida is where
wolf goes to die
he's a strong leader he doesn't waver
make America great again the problem
with Rhonda sanctimonious is that he
needs a personality transplant bigoted
white supremacist Trump wannabe we are
not going to use your tax dollars to
teach our kids to hate this country you
do not have to wear those masks we want
to wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
he wants to make America Florida yeah it
sounds good
well this is where it all began for the
man who wants to be president Daytona
Beach in Florida is Rhonda Santa's old
congressional district it's where his
political roots are and we've come to
find out what the Allure is whether that
Landslide vote for governor back in 2022
really can take him to the White House
[Music]
America Florida is his line the question
is can he and what would that look like
if I was to say Rhonda Sanchez to you
what what words come to you come to mind
you love him I love him why because I
think he sees doing the things that most
of us would like him to do he's just
he's kept Florida very young
um productive more or less I think he
wants to make America
on the way we we're used to having it
Californians are moving to Florida
Massachusetts moving to Florida Jersey
where we come moving to Florida New York
moving to Florida
must be something
bigoted
quite supremacist
um Trump want to be
I don't know what else
um what about you sir I think he'd make
a wonderful vice president under Donald
Trump actually we don't get along
politically but I try very hard to show
him the one who should come to
come away from the Dark Side
foreign
if there is one theme which gets to the
heart of what Rhonda Santos is all about
it's culture wars his war on woke we
will fight the woke in the legislature
we will fight the woke in Corporate
America we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob and yet even channeling
Churchill in Florida by no means
everyone here is buying it you know his
big thing is he wants to get rid of
wokeness and I I'm happy to be woke
myself which uh you know I feel is uh
the definition of wokeness is having
acceptance for all all types of people
and there's stuff about all the gays and
all that I'll just let them live
critics say there is a deep irony that a
man who Champions Freedom has been so
busy restricting so many different
things abortion drag shows
gender-neutral toilets and books
unfortunately we've seen some uh some
books in some of these libraries I mean
you're talking about kids in middle
school some of the stuff that has ended
up there
incredibly incredibly disturbing stuff
the governor's Grassroots support comes
from mothers like Tina so it's grown
into this our first year we sold 150 000
in t-shirts it's kind of how we funded
ourselves to start she co-founded mums
for Liberty here in Florida it now has
branches Nationwide genderqueer has
obscene images throughout it was found
here in a local Middle School library
that shared middle school and high
school and Not only was it in the school
it was on display on one of the display
cases at the end a lot of school
districts around the country have
decided that this is appropriate for as
young as sixth grade so 11 and 12 year
olds here in the United States he takes
action you know we are tired in our
country and in our state of spineless
leaders who changed their mind who flip
flop who go with the flow what we saw
with Governor DeSantis is he looked at
facts and he made decisions even though
they were unpopular this was once a
swing state not anymore though down the
coast in one of Florida's few remaining
Democratic counties teacher Denise
sufrin is considering leaving altogether
he touts that we're the free state of
Florida and I don't understand how he
could possibly say that when you are
restricting the rights because you know
the moms for Liberty will say you know
we're protecting children well what
about all the other parents that want
their children to be exposed to ideas of
All Sorts so their children can grow
you know and befriend and be kind and
compassionate and empathetic the
principles that this country was founded
on were freedom and this governor
is not for freedom for all people he's
only for freedom for certain people
his legislation dubbed by critics don't
say gay has even pitted him against
Mickey Mouse Disney the state's biggest
taxpayer publicly opposed his laws in
turn he said it was a purveyor of woke
ideology Mickey Mouse is suing the
presidential candidate
Santa's backstory is one of an American
action man the education was as
establishment as it gets Yale and
captain of the baseball team then
Harvard the Navy followed a military
lawyer in Guantanamo then Iraq with the
Navy Seals
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your Governor speaking it perfectly
fits the image he now presents
this though is the bitter battle ahead
once allies make America great again now
not so much the problem with Rhonda
sanctimonious is that he needs a
personality transplant both want to be
the next Republican president both share
the same ideals but is De Santa's Trump
without the chaos a man who could
deliver his conservative policies
exciting or frightening in a bitterly
divided country